the hype for no man's sky has basically
vanished but a strange series of events
has brought the game back into the
spotlight I'm Tony and this is your
hacked gamespot news update developer
hello games tweeted out a simple
statement no man's sky was a mistake the
tweet originated from LinkedIn which was
later deleted with the account set to
private a tweet from director Sean
Murray's account later said that the
real mistake was quote using LinkedIn
without two-factor authorization his
account also stated that the studio
servers were hacked so the disparaging
tweet about the game being a mistake and
even Sean Murray's follow-up tweets may
not have come from anyone at hello games
we've reached out to the team for
further comment no man's sky has seen
plenty of criticism since launch
including a temporary shutdown of the
game subreddit but today's hack if
that's indeed what it was seems quite
malicious will report back when hello
games has more to say and for all the
latest from the gaming world you're
already in the right place